alibaba singles day which is
amazon's prime day right alibaba's
singles day post virus
ends up doing 56 billion
dollars let me say that one more time
singles day
does 56 billion dollars in a day
amazon for their prime day this year
they did
3.5 billion dollars 3.5 billion versus
56 billion dollars
we're talking 16 times is what they did
uh singles day was created by alibaba
exec jackman daniel zhang
as a foil to valentine's day the date
11-11 was picked because it looks like
bear branches single and unattached
we feel even lonelier now alibaba kicked
off
sales a little earlier this year as of
12 30 30 a.m local time consumers spent
56.3 billion
uh on products to move all the products
around alibaba's logistics
arm prepared three thousand chartered
flights and cargo ships three million
logistic workers and ten thousand
mobile lockers to get this done what do
you think about i mean
yeah the legislation is six billion
against three point five billion yeah
you know what i don't begrudge these
guys how rich they are
you know bezos and and jack by the way
how is jack ma
only worth 40 billion no he did
he just crossed a hundred million
dollars you know when you see a picture
of jack you kind of get the idea why
uh he wasn't getting a lot of dates on
valentine's day and he had to create
this
but hey i'm sure he's getting dates now
though oh my god can you imagine
hey here's a little fun fact about um
guys 4-8 about uh
singles day just the amount of bras they
sold on the first day 1.6 million bras
how would you get if you stacked them up
it would be three times higher than
mount
everest isn't that unbelievable that's a
lot of bras to move in china
you know they sold 1.6 million bra just
on the first day
and i think this is i think this hit a
hundred billion you know because they do
it longer it's more than just one day
they go and go and go i think it's a
great sign that the economy is strong
if china china where they started the
virus
you know is doing this well with their
economy is a good sign but it also
reflects
on the fact that the pandemic people are
shopping from home more
those are staggering numbers the
logistics of what you just talked about
the amount of planes and how these guys
coordinate this thing we get ticked off
if our amazon delivery is 15 minutes
late
can you imagine what's going on in these
warehouses where they have to like
you know that maybe that's why it's so
hard to work for amazon and they run
such a tight ship but
i think it's staggering i think it's
unbelievable and i hope uh i hope it's a
sign
of good things for the economy if
china's having this much success
always reassuring when there's 1.5
million bra selling it's always a good
thing but what are your thoughts about
this a lot of
numbers a lot of titties are being
thanked on um singles day protected yeah
protected good for them i mean speaking
of jack ma
what was the big news from him last week
that he launched the
the largest ever ipo ever
with well exactly well the ant group i'm
not sure necessarily sure it flopped is
that was that was that what the uh
what do you mean the final news would
flop
what i what actually happened did it
what happened i'm asking it didn't
happen it didn't happen no
he was launching it and then what what
the chinese government kind of stepped
down
they stopped it yeah poor jack ma what i
mean so where did how did his wealth go
from
400 uh uh 40 billion to 100 billion
overnight then i thought that
it's called your company that's 56
billion it's all because of the alibaba
the list came out yesterday he's now on
the list of 100 billion 100 billion
dollar net worth
it's him it's gates i think it's zuck
it's musk
and i'm uh one other one i'm missing one
other one musk zuck
gates no it's the renault guy it's the
it's the louis vuitton what is that oh
my god
by the way how high will that get in our
lifetime will we see somebody at 500
higher you think basically in our life
in our life you think we'll see a
trillionaire
in our lifetime who's the youngest he's
40 so let's just he lives in 90 he's
healthy he takes care of himself
uh 50 years and 50 years i think we'll
we could see a trillionaire in 50 years
but
there's also a good chance that biden
gets reelected if he gets elected for
the first time
that uh bezos could be a millionaire
well that's a
that's an interesting one right there
it'll take a it'll take more than i
think it'll take aoc for him to be a
millionaire
we need an aoc firm to be a millionaire
i think biden's not going to make him a
[Music]
millionaire